yolande s'excuser au choc de cette
nouvelle vidéo sur ipad sur plusieurs
jeux voilà ça pas une compilation vous
rappelez vous de cette musique délicate
eh ben on est sur le 2-2 - strike de
ousseynou vois ça allait je change selon
la ville c'est ça très bien c'est parti
il faut que je pense au uk aller easy
easy way et or pour la note flocons de
neige annoncée comme sa noyade il ya une
première étoile deuxième étoile tap to
have all the crack hockey de 8 à l'est
déjà mais qu'il envoie une mine de base
que je souhaite vite ou pas se changer
un je pète les faire quoi oui celle-là
faut dégager les bugs et les bras la
lutte ou moi ce que tu mon gars il avait
même coup il a remonté prouvé qu'elle
combat de boxe ne faut rien faire
donc j'ai enfin partir d'anecdotes je
disais que le yéti a donc la même coupe
que moi merci à tous allez allez allez
allez au lit rester çà de là bas et à
force de swype est vite sa maille a
brûlé le droit de rigoler observateurs
mais quoi au début il avait deux trous
21 à 6 ans elle fait un truc contre la
propagation la saf et le sexe à regarder
il fait 2 cm ça ce n'est pas possible tu
en as plus qu'une ville afin qu'on perde
mon gars ok faut sauter hors au sabotage
en place et l'ipad saloperies up la
poignée coup-de-poing tchekhov du
week-end vous personnage ça qu'on
voulait il est l'arrière dont on va le
chercher il vient de se faire manger par
un loup qui sont fous ces partis au fuji
brosse les dents et gardez moi ce
blanchissement des dents dans [ __ ] il
faudrait faire ça moi même en fait aux
mecs quoi vous qu'on est sous pression
alors cette fois vous allez voir cette
fois les mines j'estime que c'est un peu
le truc qui parlent carrément c'est vous
que tu est très méchant alors fait un
orque farmer oui c'est tout sauf d'orx
et méchant généralement aux non pas les
minots des nouvelles épreuves
j'ai pas du tout qu'il faut tourner
l'ipad qui permet à toi vous savez au
virilité hashtag virilité mais il ya
quand même un bouton pour partager ta
mort quoi c'est pas la honte
salut les copains vous pouvez donc voir
ici que je suis très nul
allez on change de jeu est maintenant
sur le deuxième jeu la peace weezy on a
récemment atteint les os windows
c'est drôle on est vraiment sûr deuxième
jeu mister jobs voyait conseillé par
million de milliers de milliards niveau
1 c'est parti
alors question vers saint jeures agents
de la station de dégoût concert geste
pour voir claquer mons et le tout
maintenant mais je vous connais vous est
faux c'est ça donc c'est une sorte de 4
mario ok c'est parti j'ai pris contrôle
à moi je fais le niveau c'est que cette
baisse s et stress au fait t'as une idée
job in the job non diamant fois mais ça
ne m'intéresse pas vous jure ce jeu je
finis au mérite
si vous êtes content ce matin notre
objectif fait rage et lucas allées sont
contents l'aca a refait leur dimanche
demain c'est leur dis mais ils seront
contents les [ __ ] ont toujours plus
de virilité dans ce corps de la home
mêmes et en fait oui à quand j'appuie en
toute logique n'avait pas de recul le
petit à petit peuple ne savais pas ça
c'est secret bien sûr secret tournage
aussi palpitante le making off d'avesnes
jeunes audois est à 50% à peu près à ça
commence à devenir des fourberies assez
faux au nom 80% pouvez-vous survivre un
nom au real et on était mort là comme
des merdes au nom au mont-gaillard on
passe tout là haut en bas on à sa fin la
dixième tentative c'est pas beau ça sur
les pattes mesurage pas soyez pas des
bosses et aux hommes qui parlent guère
arrêtent des mots fois relâche les
petites charges ahmed excuse quand je
perds je vois des je te rassure je suis
un pokémon je suis là on te du jeu vidéo
je suis la honte sur beaucoup trop de
vitesse au met mais c'est pas possible
mais c'est pas possible
en fait vous vouliez compenser votre
frustration en voyant ma frustration
vous dites ah je suis pas le seul à
rager sur ce pôle a passé et si vous
vous amusez bien avec mr jobs
oui beaucoup non pas vraiment il ya un
travail sur soi qui doit être fait et
foggia d'étudier en chantant quand
j'avais cinq systèmes d'autodéfense en
fait mon corps se dit ah [ __ ] il se
dit rien là il fait là
je déteste se pique au jeu m'en fous je
pense rester vous quitte à finir à à 22h
à un moment où celui-ci un objectif on
se fie mon fils est un objectif dans la
vie on se le fist pas c'est lui qui va
finir par être fister a oui
[Musique]
ça on la joue dans le démontre comment
dire vous êtes d'accord 82% à malpassé
un meilleur jeu de stratégie non j'avais
coup sûr mais je le voyais de moi je
voyais il me regarder comme ça sans mal
[ __ ] mais ça voilà ce qui vous fera ce
jeu il vous fera possédée par un [ __ ]
de démons non mais je vous dis dans mes
séries dites voilà cbc bénédicte cbc
véronique je vais faire comme le non pas
pour faire un gène qui damas mais pour
gagner à ce jeu donnez moi votre énergie
peuple de france là on est sur une bonne
à donner en plus appuyé
donc ça la vérité sur ce jeu dès qu'un
complot dit bida petit bonjour je
m'appelle by k voici un conseil pour
éviter de casser votre tablette sous
l'orage mettait l'ipad en position
latérale de sécurité sur le côté des
pieds la protection qu'offre le net on
est maintenant sur le troisième je sors
jury simulator il ya quelque chose qui
va pas dans mon estomac j'ai besoin
d'une chirurgie d'estomac telbec et les
francos quoi moi j'ai un chemetov le
douloureux en fait ce mec qui essuieront
gérer sait déjà ce qu'il faut lui faire
c'est génial or a voulu piquer dans le
bras comme ça on met ça autour on prend
sa petite tension bien sûr on a pu
propos de peau de couette est ce assez
pour faire blanchissement des dents
qu'est ce que c'est que ça il faut
trouver le problème il est imbriqué dans
l'estomac assez bien c'est qu'on n'est
pas du tout assisté quoi en fait on un
[ __ ] de stagiaires on nous dit tout ce
qu'il faut faire un exemple en nous il
faut lui faire une manucure qu'est ce
que c'est que ce bordel
choisissez les instruments pour
commencer l'opération il nous faut ça il
nous faut ça premièrement né trois yeux
de mes et je l'envoie au plat au plat
ouais bah c'est ça l'humilie moi devant
mes abonnés on écarte ça c'est les
écarteurs c'est comme pour les oreilles
mais en un peu plus hardcore estomaqué
la direccte qui fait coucou on va dedans
hop là ça c'est une pince à épiler on
est pile un peu ce cas là dedans il a
retiré briquet il met de la glu hors
coûts bien sûr avec une cornemuse
et après le pq voilà bonjour jeune homme
allez on va ton père et mon grand bien
là allait bien pour la charité a d'abord
écouté le battement de son coeur
écoutons tout va bien monsieur on rase
le téton ah non pardon alors il nous
faut les instruments donc ça on a plus
de thunes efforts d'acheter proches ou
très bons fous je vais fermer la
première opération jusqu'à avoir assez
de sous pour opérer le coeur du monsieur
à temps mais je dois racheter le mais
après je peux plus faire aucune
opération même il nous prend par les
sentiments il faut qu'on paye 3 dollars
pour acheter de quoi sauver un mec parce
qu'il a mal au coeur c'est honteux c'est
une honte je suis outrée web avant les
gens signent la fin de cette petite
vidéo sur ces quelques jeux ipad très
sympathique j'espère que ça va plus
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
que d'habitude et puis ont surtout
retrouvé dans une prochaine vidéo
à bientôt à sa fin s'alarme ca que tout
le monde à bientôt
novice